stand on the equator and you'll be
moving out 1670 km/h faster than the
speed of sound that's how quickly Earth
rotates on its axis from west to east
and that rotation is largely responsible
for the distribution of every desert
forest and swamp on the planet so let's
do a little experiment let's say we
reverse Earth's rotation what then
well you'll change a lot more than just
the sunsets this may seem like a
ridiculous scenario at first but
scientists have actually run simulations
for a backwards spinning earth because
it happens to be a great way to test how
well we can model our planet so let's
pretend we have a big red button and
presto
now as Earth slows down to reverse
direction everything would go flying to
the east so the whole process will leave
a huge mess but let's take a look at the
equator once Earth has gotten back up to
speed these are the trade winds which
normally blow westward due to Earth's
rotation so on backwards earth they
reverse and that's where things get
interesting
at first changes would be relatively
small hurricanes for example would no
longer travel from east to west across
the Atlantic and westbound flights would
suddenly be much shorter compared to
eastbound not so bad right let's fast
forward a few thousand years into the
future changes and overall rain patterns
would turn Africa's Sahara Desert from
this to something more like this in fact
one simulation estimated that the
deserts of the world would shrink from
42 million square kilometres to 31
million providing new plant life which
would absorb more carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere potentially offsetting
the extreme warming effects from climate
change Wow
maybe we really should reverse Earth's
rotation but hold on if the trade winds
reverse direction it means that other
wind patterns
- including the prevailing westerlies
that normally blow east across the
northern atlantic and bring warm winds
from the ocean to northwest europe
keeping winters mild but on backwards
earth the westerlies reverse and instead
europe is bombarded with cold winds from
russia as a result scientists estimate
winter temperatures would drop by up to
10 degrees Celsius in fact most of the
north atlantic would grow colder
simulations show that the Gulf Stream
which normally transports warm tropical
waters to the north would reverse and
shrink in North America the landscape
would change drastically
for example the iconic deserts of the
American Southwest would disappear and
become the deserts of the southeast
instead and while you're packing up to
move to the beautiful new green pastures
of Arizona take a look at the horizon
and enjoy that peculiar sunset to the
east